hello hello hello how is everybody doing
and welcome to Episode a hundred and
sixty one assumes a left go podcast yeah
you didn't get your voice to be like
mine can you even get your voice to be
like mine so if I'm hanging on my
brother we didn't exact I was of it if
if me and my brother are drinking or if
I get tired he says that I turn into the
Batman voice oh and I'll I'll be like
Jason I don't know what you're talking
about and he's like why does your voice
get like that and I'm like I don't know
I've certain you do that before I feel
like some of my voices really have come
out because of you you've kind of coax
them out over the year well we know that
your when you're speaking about other
draft evaluators and they're dumb right
if you do the fill some cool rocker good
so we're a little excited because we
spent the morning hanging out with Joe
Montana yeah
the real Joe Montana the real one and I
pitched him my Niners Odell Beckham 1981
theory and that's all coming up in a
little bit but he's the man he is the
man he's legitimately Joe cool he's I
know that's why I mean you'll Joe relax
I had to ask him yeah Joe relax Joe
unfazed by anything oh we're in an
interview with Sims and Lefko great it's
pretty crazy that you could think you
could get that big and then you just
spend a day like people just want to
talk to you and he it's about the heart
he wanted to you know help with heart
disease and coverage and all that but
like when you can accomplish something
in your life and then the rest of your
life people will be like I'll pay money
cuz to be around you I mean he's in
another stratosphere like he's in
different register than your dad's what
they're not even in the same
stratosphere they're not in the same one
I thought they were yeah yeah I don't
think they are and the funny thing is
and people here in the here in the
interview because I bring this up but I
think my dad SEM I thought he was in his
stratosphere you didn't bring it up you
said it to him before before you did not
save it for the hawk I was really pissed
right now I guess I will so but yes I do
think there was a point in time where my
dad
like maybe he was in the same
stratosphere and he was sitting there in
the airport one day and he's sitting off
in the corner and he sees a russia
people and he can't understand and he
sees oh it's Joe and they'd you know Joe
and he just I remember he called me on
the phone that night yeah so Joe Montana
in the airport tonight Miami just forgot
how big time he was I mean man he's a
big deal I mean the people were all over
me you know it was like when I went to
the Super Bowl I was walking with Phil
and he had all the autograph people
coming over and you don't realize how
many people pointed him and go yes right
but Joe Joe I mean Joe can make millions
a year just signing things right right
and doing those site like so going to
autograph signing auctions or whatever
else doing things like that like I know
this is for charity right but for
whatever it may be be the spokesman of
this I mean the price he must demand or
command is probably impressive so he was
the the Skechers guy we didn't talk
about this but I think it's really funny
like you know that like Skechers are
making a comeback in like the fashion
scene I'm not even kidding
wait there's a dad shoe movement going
on right like the ugly shoe movement
I've heard about kind of so who was it
called Oh
Balenciaga I think it was came out with
like a very clunky dad type of shoe
right and then it launched all these
other shoe companies to like want to
make dad shoes now like the air monarch
which is like the most dad shoe ever and
then you show it to me yes yeah and then
Skechers like the stuff that he we used
to rock and it was a good joke these are
the air monarchs these bad boys these
were like scientifically proven to be
the most dad shoe when Nike put out
their shoes they had a creator say we
want to make a shoe for dads it was
never called that but this guy went and
was like okay well they typically like
white gray and blue and they typically
like this it's the highest selling shoe
I think in Nike history right yes
because every freaking dad has that's
not a bad I'd like to wear that with my
khakis right now like a nice pleated
khaki hermano right but my wife was
showing me something about like how ugly
sneakers are like becoming in fashion
right now but I'm not gonna say that
like the Skechers were like that cool
no they were ugly yes I'm saying yeah
they're ugly I'm getting there they're
making like a movement because if you
look at like some of the Kanye's like
this is what people don't realize the
number one fashion influencer and this
is supposed to be a football podcast the
number one fashion influencers probably
Kanye and what is Kanye a father of
three you know what I mean like and he's
wearing like the bulky chunky
sweatshirts all this stuff he's a dad
hey listen I I don't get it I know my
wife likes to buy his clothes to it I'm
just like okay whatever that's good I
know I'm a little bit of a hater uneasy
yeah we saw that with my with more tell
us I know I'm a hater Specht the music
and I'm when the music comes out it's
jamming I just actually don't like the
guy I don't like him I disagree yeah
that's cuz you're not in the player spot
you know why you know what my money my
biggest reasons is but I'm not gonna go
there for right now to move on alright
so joe Montana's coming up in a little
bit 6161
because Godfrey left guard for the New
York Giants great I'm gonna I'm gonna
list a team and you tell me if you can
get the guy Roger Maris Denver the
Broncos parodies yes Center Matt
parodies Indianapolis Indianapolis oh
gosh I know this one nope I don't go
center Anthony Fabiana I am the Chiefs
Oh
it's Mitch Morris Mitch more style the
Patriots this is crazy you can even do
this only 61 on the Patriots yeah didn't
even play it much this year right Marcus
cannon Oh cannon well yeah that's right
I had to burn yep
I forgot cannon was still there I was
the Raiders the r8 is Rodney Hudson yes
and the fluffy Eagles Kelsey's not 60 no
he's not 62 is Kelsey yeah to his left
to his left Newsnight that's pretty good
that you can get those okay thanks
how about this we're interviewing Joe
Montana yeah his two centers right both
were 61 I wish I knew Jesse Sapolu yeah
four-time Super Bowl champ for San
Francisco for like a decade and a half
right and Tim grunt he went to the
Chiefs and that was the the Center for
the Chiefs for like the decade that's
crazy
for 61 and Joe is 16 which is the
reverse 61 Wow that's actually I would
have liked to have done that to him
rich saw the RAM Center for the 70s
robbie tobik falcons and Seahawks in 90s
and 2000's Nick Hardwick are the
Chargers Steve Everett first-round pick
on the Browns and Nate Newton Nate
Newton big Nate okay so was Nate the one
that got into the drug trouble yes and
now he like completely cleaned up lost
like now like works for the Cowboys
right
what so I've always heard so many Larry
Allen stories yeah but Nate knew and
Newton was always listed as a great
offensive lineman he was I mean he went
to six Pro Bowls to all pros like wow
good was named back in that day
I mean Nate Newton was I felt like the
first guy I learned about like I learned
about him before Larry Allen right it
was just the hey-oh Dallas Cowboys their
offensive line it's so big it's so ever
overpowering and of course he was a
great personality unlike Larry Allen who
was a little more quiet reserved yeah
Larry Allen was like the big dude that
put up a lot of weight but didn't talk a
lot yes exactly right but no I think
like their who's who's a guy we would
say that's like that today I mean listen
he's a true road grader he's not like it
necessarily the guy you always wanted to
just go out and pull out on the edge
right but didn't matter the size of the
human being in front of him he would be
able to move them back all right so we
are recording this on a Tuesday because
Tuesday going up on a Tuesday because I
have jury duty tomorrow what oh yeah
loser tonight call tonight because
sometimes they can cancel your thing the
night before and then you don't have to
go yes I've gotten out of it twice that
way where it's actually my case got
canceled oh and it tailed at least on my
form it said call the night before you
go I have a bad feeling that I'm gonna
be involved in like a three-month court
case I hope you're involved in the most
intricate murder murder trial ever and
you have to balance that and this all
together I don't know if they they won't
let you go to work they don't even let
you go to my prom I'm just gonna be like
listen I have a podcast and I talk way
too much
and you're guilty that's a yes there
that's all you I'm a personality on TV
or on the internet but I also kind of
want to get stuck at a 30-month court
case I think the content coming out of
it would be incredible well yeah okay
fine then do it all right but one guy
that's been on trial YES on rightfully
so
Odell Beckham jr. hmm and we're talking
about it because Ray Lewis was on Colin
Cowherd show and I want to say something
first Colin Cowherd kind of set Ray
Lewis up I rewatched the clip but Colin
coward said this he goes ray Odell
Beckham jr. was on the market and he
said nobody made an offer for him and
the Rams vetted him and apparently from
what I heard didn't like what they found
so do you know anybody that's it were
people offering were they calling like
yeah yes a lot of people called the New
York Giants right yes and the big thing
is the big talk in the NFL was find out
what he's really like behind the scenes
gotcha yes but then the Rams not liking
what they heard nobody's been able to
confirm and I'm not gonna add to this
this talk right he's kind of they just
like threw it in there and that's the
reason why because there are two
swimmers in the NFL out there right now
okay about Odell Beckham jr.
and I'm not gonna talk about them
because I don't think they did no rumors
they're room all right so if you want me
to talk about it I don't think so okay
fine but they are there I don't want to
give them any justification because they
are rumour
nobody is enabled to confirm it whether
I talk to head coaches or GM's or
whatever everybody's heard these things
no there are two rumors that are saying
that he has bad character or these he's
doing things but I don't know I think
once you start putting them out there
then he has to defend himself against it
and that's kind of what happened with
Ray Lou yes right so Ray Lewis was asked
this you know what do you think about
Ray or he said Colin said what would you
say to Odell and Ray said quote when
there is no God there is chaos
I started to see started to dist himself
a little more and a little more and a
little more listen to me I don't care
about religion I'm talking about
foundation when your foundation is
disturbed when everything you are doing
is the opposite of what got you to this
place then you are making your own life
hard you tell me that we're going to be
accountable that we're going to read
Bibles and share Scripture and then it
kind of goes away now Odell responded on
Instagram by posting four videos of him
with his family praying and like his
family like holding his hand he's
holding his old grandmother's hand and
he wrote the CAPTCHA underneath the
foundation was installed at birth we
will survive and prevail always God
willing and they like they were praying
to Jesus and I watched all four clips
right it sounds I heard you talking
about this on PFT earlier it sounds like
Ray Lewis was like I'm gonna help you
yeah and then Odell was like thank you
Ray
and then Ray was like texting him every
day and it just seems like O'Dell
stopped texting back and I'm just gonna
say as someone that's closer to Odell's
age than Ray Lewis's age that I probably
don't need like someone texting me every
day for their benefit like I don't know
like it's really just to like make ray
feel like he's involved I don't I don't
think I don't think Odell needs guidance
but I sure as hell see a lot of people
trying to be his guide Yeah right that's
what I'm seeing again for the nine
million time I mean what are we
correcting like a guy that cares about
football oh he has emotional outbursts
on the field cuz he wants to win if he
was the opposite we'd all go oh I think
it's the 3-second video
it's a 3-second video sure but we were
talking about him before the three
second video because it was the boat
trip and oh my gosh he proposed to the
kicking net and it's all the same crap
it's just he's under a microscope but
like everybody's guide but the the guy
like these Chris Carter yeah I'm gonna
get there like the thing with like Ray
Lewis all right first of all right lewis
and chris carter like i have a lot of
respect for the both of them I really do
but I also think that they gotta
remember what it was like when they were
25 or 26 years old too okay I mean and
they certainly one should remember it's
those right they were not perfect and
I'm also saying just hearing from all
the outside noise all the time I'm sure
at that age they were like gosh okay I
got enough people telling me to correct
my life or whatever shut up everybody
and this is Odell Beckham jr. who's way
more famous and way more popular than
Ray Lewis and Chris Carter ever were at
they're putting that point of their
career so I'm with you like but what we
talked about a little bit to me it
sounds like ray reached out Oh Dell
Beckham jr. is a respectful guy he
respects the game I'm sure he looks up
to Ray and he's going cool
oh right I would love for you to call me
every now and then and you know we'll
talk and if I have any issues you can
just there with my friends you do that
with your friends hey man keep kicking
ass right awesome whatever yeah but it
seems like it might have connect you
said not everyday but maybe raise call
ins twice a week playset hexton everyday
ray said you tell me that we're going to
be accountable that we're gonna read
Bibles and share Scripture and I'm
thinking I already could tell that ray
took it too far
like I could already tell that Odell's
like yeah man let's keep in contact and
Ray was like everyday yeah that's just
that's come on nobody wants to deal with
that I mean it's nobody wants to have
that pushed upon them he wants to live
his life he wants to be a little
conscious free right now so be it it's
what also makes him awesome on the
football field and I just yes there's
too many people trying to get at Odell
Beckham jr. and we're gonna talk about
every little thing in the world yeah I
just like when I hear Chris Carter Ray
Lewis and again I respect him both and I
would say this right to their faces I
think that they went through both some
very like crazy things in their life
whether it was drugs or accusations and
Ray's case and then they came out the
other side and now they look back at
that as like 45 year old men and they go
you got to get away from them yeah but
they they're not they're not talking to
Adele like he's 25 they're talking to
him like he's 45 well and they're
talking and you're right he's more
famous than they ever ever were any
horrible
he and he's talking and they're talking
to him like he has the issues they had
and I want to go no he has not been
accused of murder or has a serious drug
program some problem sorry that's not
what it is
no I mean we're taught the worst thing
he's done is maybe he allegedly he had a
blunt in his hand in a hotel room in
France oh my god let's call the
authorities let's go over to Paris
France and inspect the room to make sure
if it was a marijuana blunt or not I
mean who gives a damn first of all
nobody even cares I know okay but we're
gonna continue to add that onto the pile
of thing well it wasn't turned it but
about the notion of the jilted guide
right so here's Chris Carter supported
him to no end last offseason he was like
the mouthpiece right and this year he's
tired of it and then Ray Lewis I tried
to reach out but so you know if you're
going to be the teacher for
you then can't publicly bash them when
they say I don't need your teaching
anymore right like if anything your your
teachings continue your teachings it
doesn't matter you're not doing this
just for Odell Beckham jr. I'm not a
religious person right me neither but
James 3:1 I looked it up this afternoon
not many of you should become teachers
my brother's for you know that he who
that we who teach will be judged with
greater strictness so that's my thing
yeah you're gonna teach someone they
don't want your teachings anymore and
then you're gonna make it worse for them
they're they're the two biggest critics
in the last three weeks I've been Chris
Carter and Ray Lewis I just think it's
messed up to someone like O'Dell
understand what he's going through at
any time you add fuel to that fire
you're making it was just player two
player world right like I mean just just
in that alone it's it's just that right
it's you know respect the player okay I
mean this is this is Odell Beckham jr.
and he is in a certain point of his life
in his career and he doesn't want to be
corrected and just managed and looked
over at all times I don't really know
what of the other way to put it yeah man
we get really defensive Odell well I
mean it's ridiculous the amount of
attention yeah I mean uh you know again
I don't know we're talking about oh my
gosh II he went to OTAs he went to the
first day of training camp he went to
the first day of workouts all season
training program oh my gosh let's make a
story about it I can't believe he's
there cuz he's always there and he never
misses anything but it's amazing he's
there this time I mean that's what I
don't get I'm realizing that today's
episode in addition to Joe Montana is
going to be the spiritual and religion
episode did you know that the spiritual
leader of our generation apparently had
a special guest today spiritual leader
of our generation yeah gosh who is our
spiritual leader met with the Dalai Lama
he met with the Dalai Lama yeah okay
what person is this what person is the
Pope it is not the Pope can I have some
audio please really quick
the Dalai Lama met with our spiritual
leader Aaron Rodgers in India Wow
yes I hope he paid proper respects there
and also to the the Packers quarterback
is on a trip with his girlfriend Danica
Patrick as part of a philanthropic
mission with Starkey Hearing Foundation
giving hearing aids to many who don't
have access otherwise Rogers gave the
Dalai Lama a hat and a ball and then
Mike McCarthy said we're gonna change
the offense see what happens when you
see the Dalai Lama I like to welcome
those that are unaware that they've
stepped into a place of worship this is
the Church of Aaron Rodgers we
maintained a few core beliefs here yes
we do while not the creator or the son
of the creator Aaron Rodgers is the BFF
of the Creator Aaron Rodgers right arm
is the holy spirit yes and if you ever
commit a sin you shall repent with one
Hail Mary from Aaron Rodgers against
your favorite team that is how you shall
repent we Sims and Lefko warmly invite
you to connect and participate in the
Church of Aaron Rodgers man
yeah that is some bad elevator music
there right there gosh that musics weird
that is on YouTube relaxing Church music
but yeah I saw the picture and I was
like the Dali Lama met with Aaron
Rodgers jeez yeah so he's travelling
around with Danica I guess they're
serious huh yeah I saw him like kissing
her before a race Sam Aaron Rodgers and
Danica Patrick why don't you ask a good
question right who is driving home who
is driving home I want to know that's
that's what I really do want to know I'm
letting her drive as we've talked about
yeah you you would scare Danica with the
way that you drive I don't know about
that Danica would get in the car but
whoa slow down stop lanes Danica sit
back but what if she was the opposite
she was like is this stick okay good
let's go for it
but Aaron Rodgers and Danica Patrick
yeah yeah that's interesting it is
interesting yeah but I saw that picture
of the Dalai Lama and I was like wow it
goes perfectly into our little religious
thing here yes it is not another one
Baker may feel
and that with a psychic at the combine
Wow and they pulled cards and it and he
was went in very skeptical and he left
he was like okay that was a little bit
too much like talking about his mom and
all that stuff but the card that he
pulled was the Arizona Cardinals and he
reacted in a way in which he was like
wow this is a team that definitely loves
me he pulled out he's like oh my god he
goes if this happens then we're gonna
have to and so now I'm really rooting
for Baker Mayfield to go the the psychic
afterwards they asked her you know what
vibe did you get from him what kind of a
career do you see and he was she was
like wow I see I don't know when but I
see Super Bowls in his future and I see
a great career and this happened to the
combine you're saying yeah I can find
the clip while you don't go walk into
like some random bar and Indianapolis
and family I think it was the NFL set
this up and then they went in there here
I'll read you I'll play you the end
there's some could find this this is
compliments of the NFL so this is him
pulling the Cardinals so he goes and
he's he's reaching and watch he pulls
the Cardinals and here's his reaction
yep this turns out to be true there's
gonna be some good stuff all right
you could tell it's like old man they
really like me literally like he walked
out of a meeting just with them and as a
confident they told me they're gonna
draft me exactly happens I feel really
good with this kid where he's going he's
gonna end up going to the Super Bowl I
feel really good with him yeah I don't
know what year I just say superbowl
around this kid I'd like to know this
woman's scouting report we need to do
our I need to watch some film on the
show I wanna see her Mach where her
results okay wait so do you believe in
psychics I do a little bit yeah I do
there's there's some things there
certainly that you know that horoscopes
like I'll take it with like a grain of
salt
I think horoscopes are not so now
they're not all nonsense the only reason
I think they're not I think that
horoscopes like the daily horoscopes I
could read you one for a Virgo or for an
Aquarius I'm a Virgo but I can read you
an Aquarius you like oh that's me I
don't me I don't think so you don't
thinks I don't I don't because I've had
this game like we have this book in my
house right where you it'll break it
down like by day and it's actually
hilarious like if you go to your
birthday like my birthday is August 29th
1980 and it's scary how all over like my
day and my there in my brain this book
and we this is a fun like drinking game
we do at times at the Sims household
where we'll sit around all day all right
so the the three main characteristics of
an individual born under this modality
I've entered your birthday very flexible
likes almost every change that's not
true yes what is this deals with unhook
situations very well all three of those
are the absolute opposite I've never
heard that about Virgo ever
you're on Virgo right now I'm on the
horoscope I guess 29th 1980
I once I went to a psychic and they like
she looked at my palm and she's like wow
you're your life and love line or
enormous you have amazing things
destined for you yeah well I was like
that's the equivalent of ordering from a
waiter and you're like I love the sea
bass he goes
excellent choice and you're like oh wow
that validation was perfect thank you
but I've been like how many times do you
think they look at them and go you have
awful luck nobody likes you in your life
Charlotte I was at the DeBartolo house
okay the DeBartolo I didn't know we were
going here cuz this is like one of my
but the DeBartolo house for a fundraiser
back when I'm playing for the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and mr. DeBartolo the old
owner of the San Francisco 49ers he
could throw a party and he was the
coolest guy around I mean he really was
there couldn't be a nicer guy than mr.
DeBartolo so he invites us to this this
event at his household Casa de de Barlow
okay yeah because it's big and there is
a you know what do they call like the
one that reads the cards the same thing
she is tarot cards the card is that one
of this and my wife went up to him and
my wife will still talk about this woman
to this day cuz like not that she was
exactly specific but she talked about
certain cities you're gonna move to that
we were gonna have a kid in the city and
a kid in that city and she predicted all
she was all over it and my wife like for
the longest time was like I can't
believe it this is what this woman said
three years ago she said we were gonna
go to a city Boston yeah you'd have to
ask her all the details see stories I'm
a believer that no it's Jen and your
wife is like you're living in Boston
you're like that's psychic 15 years ago
so that we were gonna have a baby yeah I
know I get you I get here I just thought
they're not gonna be ultra specific but
there are some genuine I'm gonna show a
psychic yeah fine that's what we should
do before I'm gonna bring this book in
and read your birthday it's gonna be
spot-on but I also think that before the
NFL season next year yeah we make our
year-end predictions for Super Bowl
winner and stuff we should bring in a
psychic okay
tarot card reader well I like that I
like that too all right so let's go to
our interview with Joe Mantegna Joe
Montana Joe Montana
bed senior he was awesome it's a
30-minute conversation and also pay
attention when he talks about heart
disease because you could tell it
impacts him a lot that's the reason we
got a chance to meet with him today and
I hope you guys enjoy it
here's us with Joe Montana
we're best kids got a great class yeah
he went to the cap clap combine came
back y'all ready to go uh we're here
with the man the myth yes I don't think
it's a myth
he's just the man and a legend like
there's no myth like he's the man and a
legend right how you doing man um
hanging in there welcome to New York oh
thank you what are you doing out here
Oh my wife Jennifer and I are working
with Amgen on them on a awareness
campaign for heart disease right they
called break away from heart disease and
we're just out here spreading the word
trying to get everyone to get out there
and understand that this is kind of a
silent killer and it's you should get
with your doctor and make sure that it's
not affecting you and if so get a game
plan and get yourself on the right track
hopefully we can save a few lives along
the way yeah you know actually it's
funny heart disease is kind of like a
silent killer like what you don't
realize I know my wife actually brought
this up to me about heart disease like
drinking it's one of the number one I
guess issues for heart disease so you
wouldn't expect that but hey all you
drinkers out there type it down a little
bit yeah well I think what's interesting
Joe is like so you guys have your life
right and you go out there and you chew
all this stuff and people probably ask
you about your past all the time and
then you reach a point in life you're
like okay I'd like it to stand for like
more than just a sport what is my cause
and you picked heart disease it seems
like and I'm curious why is it so
important to you to spread this message
well a number of reasons both of us have
heart disease on our side of the family
Shore on both sides of the family her
father passed away it's 60 from heart
disease my my mom had high blood
pressure and high cholesterol her two
brothers and had heart attacks my
grandfather passed away at 54 and I
think one of the things is is is your
family history has a lot to do with you
are our kids we want to make sure that
they're prepared and the opportunity
came along that get
the word route to a much larger audience
and or so we thought it was a great idea
especially since it's so close I mean I
was diagnosed with high blood pressure a
couple years after I retired just I went
simply for a physical and it we did my
blood pressure was really high
I kept monitoring monitoring I kept
going how it's gonna go down it's gonna
go and it didn't
we worked odd kind of a game plan for me
it's that's why we say get with your
doctor or you can get on our website to
break away from heart disease calm yeah
there's a lot of great information even
before you see your doctor well that's a
great jumping-off point actually because
I mean Joe cool with the elevated heart
rate that doesn't write a commercial
writes itself right he was cool on the
football field but his blood pressure
was rising break away from heart disease
can but I'm dead serious it's one of the
first questions I want to ask you like
what actually makes you so cool like
really like even just standing around
here look he's dressed like Johnny Cash
okay okay and then I mean whether it's
all the times you came back and like
I've said before we got on camera ruined
some childhood sundaes by being clutched
in the fourth quarter I mean 1988 got
bombed down the sideline to Jerry Rice
silence in the middle and showed me that
clip it was like you know they're so
credible this I'm dead serious as I'm
waxing poetically about you what is it
the way you were brought up what is it
about you even in clutch situations in a
game where you were able to keep your
cool and be that kind of guy I I think
one of the things I found out as as my
career went on especially especially
when I got to San Francisco was you know
the the more I was prepared and the more
I prepared myself the easier not the
easier the game came but things out
there were easier to deal with because I
had seen him so many times
Bill Walsh I mean he wanted perfection
from the quarterback he will you know
back when we played we didn't have the
graphic right that's cheating right yeah
we would have we had our game plan we
had 130 pass plays on average 30 some
other and they all had two and three
formations so you you had to know
memorize the formations because we know
I got signaled to play
right and then you had to memorize what
order bill wanted those other formations
what the next time you called the same
play I matched it was very particularly
oh yeah so wait that's really
interesting so you had to memorize the
play and then throughout the week of
preparation you had to know okay these
are the three or four formations we're
running this play out and then also go
oh bill likes it in this order this
order how how is that different than
what it is now now it's I mean huge
wristbands or it's like we heard this
year with Jared Goff and Sean McVeigh
where they have the earpiece like Joe
was talking about with they're literally
breaking the huddle and the coach is
still giving them reminders and telling
them things to do do you think Bill
Walsh would have enjoyed that you know
what it was the funniest thing about
there was one photo I and I totally
forgot where I have a wristband I'm with
the thing on yeah he came up with this
idea one time he wanted to go to play a
sequence all the time and he didn't want
to waste the time signaling to shows in
so it was the only time we ever had a
wristband on that had plays written on
it otherwise bill no he he maybe if we
had a simpler way he would have gone for
it but yeah back then he I mean that was
that I spent most of my time heck
Jennifer we used to help me study study
study me up and make sure I had it by
the he was pretty good he could remember
things Jennifer pretty good he was all
over it so you're like in the living
room and she's asking about like the
budget set with the motion yeah but then
then she would tell me but but you
forgot to take the trash out yeah you
want to go there too so I think when
you're known for something it changes
the way the public reacts to you right
like Malcolm Gladwell's really smart so
everyone wants to ask him a question or
like you say buzzer welcome glad well
he's you wouldn't know then I can you
say bolts really fast and I'm sure a lot
of people are like you in a race when
you're known for being cool
what happens then like what did you
notice a lot that you were like man this
this nickname it's really changed like
people interact with me I think I
probably get the same question you know
we
what what what it enabled me to do mmm
to seem so cool and but I had the one
thing I tried to do as a person on the
on the field is I was a little bit of a
prankster and I would make fun of you in
a heartbeat
and write is and obviously I'd get it
back but I didn't care if we were in the
huddle it was the middle of the game we
were winning we're losing I just tried
to be myself the whole time and yeah I
don't know whether that helped me deal
with the pressure myself but you know
when you kneel down and you kneel and
your left tackles urine just went to the
bathroom and didn't tell you before you
got it right that's right there's
something funny about that yeah what is
that I mean so wait that happens well
yeah all I mean are gross I mean they're
gross but like okay like so Super Bowl
23 you're going out in the field for
that last Drive the clutch drive against
the Cincinnati Bengals and of course the
famous story about you pointing out Jim
Jim John Candy in the stands like did
you plan that before you went out there
was that totally organic and just kind
of happened because everybody on your
team Braves about it yeah what happened
what happened is our our starting tackle
Harris pardon yeah it was a people
person so all the time you know Super
Bowl week you would go out we'd practice
in the day we'd have dinner off and then
we come back from meetings again at
night and he was like a little kid as
the week's went on week went on more and
more celebrities were showing up in town
and he was so excited about who he saw
that night that he was like a little kid
when he saw you and so TV timeouts are
forever in the Super Bowl and I'd been
to the sidelines at least once maybe
twice and I was just standing in the
huddle and I'd met John Candy in number
years prior because my contract was
about to come up and he owned the
Argonauts and he was trying to go to
Toronto so he just happened to be framed
between two of the guys shoulders and
and I just thought well shoot member
Harris say he saw John Candy look I
figured he would appreciate it
be pointing him out and Harris always
stood he was a little bit anal and it
stand perfectly still like this and for
the whole eight minutes whatever the TV
time I was and then and then he looked
over there and he looked came back to me
start mumbling something but I always
say he appreciates it more today than he
did not actually that's your favorite
Super Bowl win do you have a favorite I
mean I know you have forties are all
different right if you look at him you
know obviously playing Cincinnati the
first time it was the first time you get
there so that first time you walk on the
Superbowl field it's different than the
next time show sure and then we go and
we play basically at home we played at
Stanford and we played Danny Marino yeah
and the Dolphins where we hit you know
kind of dominate yeah we had a good game
defense
3816 defense pretty good oh you mean
22:16 Jerry Rice and the Cincinnati
Super Bowl that would be the next what
was the fourth the fourth one was 5510
Denver Broncos five touchdown passes
over here hog over here five touch five
yes but that's a pro so they did they
took you I took you out and you don't
want that's what the one game you don't
want to come out right but they take you
out and I I assumed growing up that you
Wayne Gretzky and Michael Jordan all
hung out like I just thought that was a
thing like I would see like a commercial
I'm like man those guys are the best
friends ever
I would see Gretzky alive I didn't see
my I'm around him Michael very often but
I did see I see way a lot man
I mean when you say your Joe Cool he's
the great one right like that's pretty
good I know buddy started playing
professional when he was 12
yeah crazy yes I was like a savant one
other way I want I think just so
interesting about you and your your
upbringing and everything just the the
western Pennsylvania roots of like
quarterbacks right whether it's whether
it's you know Danny or John or Jim Kelly
or you know Joe Namath like is there
something that you look at in that area
and go I could see why I could you know
breed or whatever else bring franchise
type quarterbacks to the NFL
there was the beer the beer here toughen
you up a little bit like this I think it
came from a point in time where you know
we're in a in a tough area steel mills
coal mines and I think sports were I'm
sure there were other places like it but
it's the only thing I can think of was a
way out of a way of life right your
parents and your grandparents had and
they saw that because my mom that could
have never sent me to Notre Dame they
would never afford it so the only way
for me to get ahead and that and they I
think they saw that was to be able to
get a scholarship through sports or
right we're in another way but you think
it was a big I didn't mean to cut job
just like the steel where the steel
that's hard knows we're gonna be just
focused on our job yeah I think so and
and then you watch this Pittsburgh at
that time the Steelers were going
through a tough road and then all sudden
they they won four Super Bowls and so
being a part of that and watching that
as a kid growing up you know yeah I'll
jump pasta games kind of fun as you know
yes
well also so I went on a rant yesterday
about why the Niners can bring back the
81 Niners if they trade for Odell
Beckham because I find a lot of
similarities behind the trio that could
be in your trio Bill Walsh Kyle Shanahan
I'm gonna do the whole there give it to
him go ahead Lawson cow Santa and both
started off as assistant coaches in
California both started off somewhat
linked to the Raiders and then they go
through and they both have these
unbelievable offenses you grew up in an
Italian family in in western
Pennsylvania Jimmy Garoppolo Italian
family middle of the country both stayed
in the middle of the country neither of
you started quarterback until your
junior year of high school then you're
both drafted after the first round by a
legendary coach named Bill Odell and
Jerry Rice when the South stayed in the
south went to stay there come on man his
copy boy he wants out yeah so bad
because I when you're 81 team or
you come in an eighty right and use them
so yeah and you lead to come back and
then you go six and ten and then that
sets you up for the thirteen and three I
feel like we just saw that but they're
missing that guy they're missing Jerry
well they need some help on the outside
there someone like that would be a
definite plus form right but are you
feel that energy around the team matter
how you get rid of the guy like that
that's what I can insane job right like
it would you be mad a bill if you said
I'm good through we're thinking about
trading Jerry and we go to first-round
picks in his prime yeah okay we'll take
two to probably catch up to all right
it's just hard to get rid of a guy like
that could say he's probably the premier
guy in the league
and I just don't know how you let him
get away yes do you recognize that
people call Jimmy Garoppolo Joe Montana
[Laughter]
to bring this here it says you wouldn't
know that if he put his helmet on I
other like well I want to know why Jimmy
G I think it's still I mean these guys
play five games so far right he's he you
just don't know it's I'm hopefully yeah
for the 49ers and in the Bay Area
you know he's he'll be the difference
well the fact that he says that Odell's
the best you evaluate right like I'm
sure you watch a game you go there's
something good about that guy know
there's something about him that he's
made the transition it seems like in
that offense he understands what it
takes yeah in there you also played at
the end of the season where some
probably caught a couple teams yeah
right so I I'd love to see him now that
everybody's back in order and it's
starting from the beginning and I think
this season will be a big tell I think
so and I and I guess I hope for the
49ers day but you look at the history I
always look at is everyone who's left
behind a great quarterback like that and
left the same system boom has not had
success true there's hasn't been one
Matt castles and all those guys look at
all those guys look it all the way back
to Scott Mitchell who left short you
know had the decent career would not
great career right the guy that left
from behind Steve and went to Kansas oh
yeah I mean he was your backup in Kansas
City too wasn't he no he was after me oh
no he took enough bones bones no Burke
no I'm trying to think he backed out
oldest urban Elvis Grbac right right
yeah and yeah so you I think it's it's a
little too early for me to tell but
hopefully like I said hopefully yeah
he's made it seems like he understands
what it takes in that offense to make it
work
just cool quarterbacks man franchise
does I mean well I'm you know me I'm
checking Joe's body out too like Joe is
like you know one of these guys to look
at yeah I'm checking out Joe yep sorry
because you get well you're I always
look at anybody's oh but you I always I
mean fat you know your long worms big
fingers long hands you could tell that's
why I could throw the football left go
that's why you can throw that's why you
could spend that thing sim says he's a
master and looking at guy's body yes and
like figuring out why experts looking at
naked men and telling them why they're
good at sports
yeah well I was looking at your
nicknames because you have like a
million nicknames and one of them was
was it skinny legs bird legs bird that's
the worst one golden Joe Joe cool the
comeback kid then they had a nickname
contest in the San Francisco Chronicle
where you got named the Big Sky but then
someone said that your name sounded like
a nickname so they named you David W
Gibson yeah said I needed a real name I
already had it yeah and put it above
your locker
they sent me a plaque with it Daniel
Gibson
David W Gibson yeah yeah that's when
your name is so cool you need a less
cool actual yeah like how dare you
that's ten cool
oh the number 16 I've always wondered
this because you wore three in college
there was no I guess there was Len
Dawson before you know but no great 16s
as you were growing up we added we had
an old equipment manager and when I got
to San Francisco had been there for a
long time he said here pard this is
yours you were okay with it you just
said okay I'll roll with it all right I
got it I'll take it man that's amazing
okay I'm gonna bring up some bad
memories now okay
January 4th 1987 was that the hardest
hit you ever took in your career do you
remember that hit he might not
you got knocked a little silly I don't
know this no no that was not the hardest
this is divisional playoff game Jim Bert
we need really actually supplies it was
like really wasn't as much Jim's here as
the ground is a ground right and then
the one that was the worst he was
Marshall yes that one kind of backed
into it to it he is that a full-speed
sprint from the other side of the field
because I and I was you were so good did
you have somebody open downfield and I
just dodged LTC and I just got out of
trouble they literally said from the bet
I can still remember watching the game
as a ten-year-old and Joe is on the
bench of course beat up and my dad's not
even playing but they go the report from
the bench on Montana's everything's
hurting and I can still remember that
yeah my he compressed me but you know
how it gets when you get compressed in
the ground yeah were they kind that's
where they hurt you everything goes bad
when they try to compress you so from
that point like you had to sit out of
football basically and getting every
broke my hand right with God okay that
was what got it
yeah you I mean I could have got could
have gotten back in the game yeah had it
not been for my hand okay but my he was
spiral fractured my hand and so I
couldn't yep obviously couldn't hold and
then Steve fumbled the snap anyways and
ruined everything so didn't matter I
love you Joe I found this article today
from 1990 written by a Vito stalino so
it might be from the Italian Post
Gazette but it says that Joe Montana
vaults from fifth to first this year
when he became the first player in
league history to average more than
three million dollars a year Kirk
Cousins just got what 27 27 a year right
and a half damn I feel like there needs
to be a payment plan to like the Joe's
and the Phil Simms is and the
like I look at their contracts back then
I'm like boy here was that 1990 man
that's a yeah it's 28 years ago right
yeah you marvel at it where the games
come and that yes yes not I mean it's
great for the players
sure oh my god well he kicks himself
yeah right like the middle of the road
guys are getting 17 I know my wife is
totally clueless about football and she
saw one of the contracts like a few
weeks ago and she was like is that what
the quarterbacks are making now and I
was like yeah Banshee sick oh my gosh
she did she said that yeah I think you
can still play I want to talk about just
bill in in terms of the offense how soon
did you know oh this is different like
this is gonna be game-changing was it
early on did you have to experience
success for oh no in the beginning it
was it was difficult learning from I
came from to funny when I was at Notre
Dame under Air Parseghian he had an
offense where there were no numbers at
all it was all words right the next when
Devine came in it was almost all numbers
and no word very few words and then all
we get to bill and now you have both
words and numbers and trying the numbers
really were nothing but protection and
so I think once I found out I was just
talking with boomer boomer this morning
and we were talking about the same thing
as a the most important thing for you to
figure out is protection
yeah and if you can't figure out the
protection it's hard to take care of the
rest if else possible and so once I
start figuring out what all then because
some of the numbered and protections
like twenties were the same as a seventy
right step for one little cut of a two
bags in the backfield there one way or
the guard or the center was going one
direction or the other right strong weak
right until you figured all that part of
it out so you knew whether you were
protected enough to be able to now look
down the field from offense it so I took
it took a while to to get really
comforting
with that but I think one of the biggest
understandings is when I had a
conversation with him I think it was my
second year talking about the offense
where he said we're gonna here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna attack this
side of the field right over here and
whether it's man or zone we had all kind
of the lead way as our receivers you
could a hook could be us could be a
cross could be a hook could be us and
out it could and Jerry even turn it to
where could be a post right and just
depending on the read and so he said but
I'm also going to give you we're gonna
try to control if we get his own and
we're gonna try to control with these
other two guys down here and another one
on the other side so this is where I'd
like you to throw the ball but you don't
have to and if it's covered and it's
covered from this side of the field or
this guy's taken it away throw the ball
to this guy and getting an understanding
that it's first down he goes the thing
about defenses they're they think funny
because if I hand the ball off and on
first down you run the ball for 4 yards
what does everybody say you can't give
up four yards right drop back to pass on
first down oh I don't like the guy down
there get the ball to the tight end or
the back four yards right same four
yards yes it's a different look for them
but they feel like they stopped Yeah
right and then also and you're inside
their 20 and they're going oh how they
get down here we've been so doing so and
it's just it was getting that
understanding of where to go with the
football and when the fort when it was
time to force it the road yeah we're
trying to make a tight throw and when it
wasn't sand and that just take what the
defense was giving you we talked to big
fill every week I think we're gonna call
him again later today we bother him he's
at home at your time we call it fill-in
time
yeah just he just watches film and tells
us what we're missing
but he's talked a lot about when he
would get hit and the trash talk that
would go between him and like Reggie
White or Jerome Brown whatever he never
got to get hit by LT and I'm curious
what was that interaction like else even
he didn't really say much really
yeah and or sometimes he would say Angie
oh you better get some help over there
where your left yeah that's
he didn't really I don't think he
remember him talking allotted he talked
a little bit but not I don't remember it
ever being trash shovel did anybody talk
trash to you because my question was
probably scared of you and you got the
body your hands so quickly everyone
let's not piss Joe off he might go down
with yield on us here we had a couple in
the championship game against the
Cowboys was the Cowboys we'd beat him
earlier in the year and they were saying
a couple bunch of things
uncharacteristic of the Cowboys right
but the old Cowboys when there was one
are Harvey Martin who since passed away
right he I don't know what's the third
quarter sometime and he finally came in
now if he's sack me or he hit me and
knocked me down and you said and I will
be back and I said well I hope so cuz I
was beginning to think you weren't the
game cross was who was blocking me most
of the day said why do you got to say
that to my guy yeah Randy you've been
kicking his butt all day don't worry we
do talk to Phil I told Chris this at
dinner on Thursday night and I'm I'm on
a bash now I want to start the campaign
to get phil simms into the Hall of Fame
I think not even just as a player but
like he was the voice of the NFL for
like 20 years on a major broadcasting
and I just would like to hear you
convert no I totally agree you know you
look at I don't want say names but you
look at guys that made it in and and I
send it just overwhelms me that he's not
in there already
yeah yeah blows me away oh thank my wife
and I talk about it a bunch of times
well um I think it's I think we're gonna
launch the campaign I'm already telling
Josh that we're going to the Hall of
Fame in August because the greatest
safety of all time not name ronnie Lott
Brian Dawkins he's all messed up yeah I
want to say one more quick I want to ask
him who the best team he ever played
against before I know I have that
question will let you who is the best
team you ever played against in your
career you know other than your own
whether you beat them or lost but who's
the one team you looked at you were like
man they were so talented I don't know
all the giant
they were yeah okay what in in I know
whatever years you can pick in there
when they had that defense going right
and maybe I say there's those were those
were good teams yeah everybody talks
about the bears and bears were the bears
were a different kind of team where you
know you when they came up with that
defensive air defense so you figure till
big bill figured out how to play it
because everybody liked you you would
turn on video and go holy crap
everybody's open but the guys on the
quarterbacks get back right right and so
everybody tried to get everybody out and
then bill said okay forget that we're
gonna keep everybody in right everybody
has a responsibility to block you're on
the run and if your guy doesn't come
immediately
if he hesitates that I'll go yeah and
and if he comes
stay in block right and we'll work on
the outside and that's kind of that's
kind of what you did what we did from
that point right you guys were kind of
the code crackers of the Bears I guess
overall I think once people figured out
if you block them it's hard to well you
know it's hard to cover guys down the
field yeah with man-to-man firt extent
with Herot of time yeah with Jerry Rice
and John Taylor oh yeah yeah exactly
the reason we have Joe here today is
because we are trying to help fight
heart disease go to break away from
heart disease calm you can learn more
about the importance of understanding
the risk factors gain tools that can
help you develop your own game plan for
improving your heart health its impacted
your family it's definitely a back to my
family I think it affects everybody it
does I mean the number one killer no
doubt about it
yeah I mean my grandfather he was an
alcoholic growing up and I mean he died
of a heart attack so I'm sure that
didn't help things to the stories of
chris's grandfather unbelievable
he was like pulling teeth out of his own
head yeah well I mean he already knew
the sim family is crazy so of course
that's just that was the head Sims
craziness just just a farm in Kentucky
and then you know I I think about you
growing up and like western Pennsylvania
and like Phil Simms and like Kentucky
and like Dan Marino and I think like
what would it be like if you guys met
like a teenager's yeah they're so funny
I didn't yeah and then came a few years
behind me but not yeah no partner right
awesome thanks for being you bet see ya
Joe Cool Joe Joe super complimentary of
your pops I'm glad that I'm gonna go
with this movement okay get phil simms
into the Hall of Fame movement okay good
luck with that but I like that Joe said
that and it's interesting that he took a
few shots at quarterbacks that are in
the Hall of Fame I thought he was
talking about Kurt Warner yeah I don't
know who he was talking about either I'm
not quite sure I have some feelings
other 49er quarterbacks but interesting
dynamic that's it's trying to talk to
him afterward right about can you give
us any insight about Belichick and Brady
since you went through that with Bill
Walsh and he avoided it like masterfully
like twice either that or didn't
understand what I was asking but I
wanted him to share light on like look
man when Joe Montana got up there an
aged Bill Walsh traded him like way
before people thought he was gonna be
done and that's what I feel like the
Patriots are going through right now
with Brady and Garoppolo yeah I mean
young was the grapple Young was the
Garoppolo I mean the stories you always
heard behind the scenes right were that
young was Mike Holmgren guy right Mike
Holmgren was the OC there he was the one
that was pushing young on to Bill Walsh
and of course Young had a lot of
physical ability right of course he
could really run I mean he came out he
ran four or five and the forty coming
out a BYU but throwing was an issue but
they all saw that there was certainly
some potential there and yeah I mean
from everything you've ever heard those
stories and and I don't know these like
direct correlations but I always heard
it was a little nasty between between
those two was ultra competitive and even
filtered into the coaching staffs a
little bit about who they were sticking
up for but man Joe got the last laugh it
doesn't really matter Joe won four and
then he went to Kansas City and
Steve yes he did right so JoJo's dimin I
mean I don't know if there's really been
a maybe other than Brady I think Joe is
the only guy I can look at and go like
men in a clutch situation I don't know
if you could trust anybody more I will
say this about Joe yeah I've never seen
someone's discussion in the best
quarterback of all time
like fizzle out faster than when Brady
won five right like always it was you
know could be Marino eat the best arm
but Elway man that guy could run and
throw Montana's got four yeah as soon as
Brady got five I no longer hear Montana
being talked about as the greatest of
all time no you're right he does he's
because that was his leg up that was his
leg up and then the funny thing is of
course then you know this I don't look
at either one of them as the greatest of
all time I think the thing I look at
same with Joe is like I look at Brady it
they're more Derek Jeter than they are
Michael Jordan to me they're like really
good at their positions but they have
this amazing cool calm clutch factor to
where when things get tight they seem to
be able to execute at their best and
there's a lot to be said about that I
mean being clutches a lot of sports yeah
it's a lot of people say it's an insult
but like Derek Jeter is one of the like
you can't say anything about I mean I'm
saying Sam Donald's not the number one
or number two pick he's the number eight
pick and it's I'm a horrible person
yeah you're a I'm a hater I mean how
dare I say he go in the top ten well I
mean it's just you can't win that just I
give up with some of this crap it is
interesting that if you said a guy is
fourth in the quarterback rankings which
means he goes still goes in the top ten
right then you're saying that he's trash
yeah I mean that's the common thing I
get from some of my Boston friends
sometimes when I say Brady's the third
greatest of all time they're always like
I want to back I'm saying third greatest
of all time I'm not saying third
greatest now or like in Patriots has
game like I don't understand it like man
I have to see it that way I guess of
every person that's ever played the
position I also think though that when
you talk about say I'm darn 'old you
mention his flaws right when people that
are reverse yeah he talked about Sam
Darnell doneand Josh Allen five right
they say that I never won Josh Allen on
my team like they think that he's gonna
be such a miss right that it isn't
right whereas you're going why are we
not talking about Darnell's fumbling or
the way that he brings on pressure with
Josh Allen they go I don't think this
guy will ever make I know I don't listen
I understand the concerns of all of them
I just want I just want a fair
conversation with with everything you
know I mean that's that's my biggest
issue you know like you know we even
talked about a little bit like the
dinner loss key Orlovsky video like
where he's pointing out Josh Allen
missing a blitz see that's where to me
it goes back to our old buddy who wrote
you know ego is the enemy or holida
Bryan Holaday are talking about bias
that's where bias starts to get into
your scouting and the season now see
he's starting to make up stuff that he
doesn't really know and he's gonna
evaluate the player on something that he
doesn't know and you're saying that it's
not that he doesn't know like he doesn't
know it's football but you don't know
what's been coaching the situation you
don't know in this specific case of the
video that he put out where maybe the
back was supposed to block that guy and
he ran out into the flat and missed him
and Josh Allen wasn't expecting him
maybe the coaches taught him you know
when they played this coverage I want
you to ID'd this guy they've never
blitzed in this formation this guy's
never blitz oh we're gonna move the line
that way and don't even worry about him
maybe he was taught that see there's so
many things along the way to where you
go you don't know what happened those
are where now you'd like to meet a Josh
Allen you watched it filming what
happened here but listen the guy who
scored 37 on the Wonderlic I think he's
gonna be able to go Lutz predict the guy
I mean that's overanalyzing that's over
scouting and that shows its bias right
there because you're not just evaluating
the player now you're all of a sudden
you were in the coaching room and you
know it was supposed to happen I think
that I don't I don't want to attribute
any intelligence to Wonderlic just
because if you're gonna say you're smart
at a 37 then you got to say no I know I
got you're just saying that yes but I
I'm just saying he's obviously smart
enough to go make that guy the mic so
then when you're watching film right you
would have to see that repeatedly we're
up to go he has an issue with picking up
the blue yes and it was not me they're
gonna go he has an issue with picking up
the Blitz or I'm gonna go oh they don't
really even he's not even been taught
about the Blitz or anything they just
he's been caught he's been taught his
offensive line is gonna pick everything
up right
you just react off of it which happens
in college football it's the way I
really was taught in college football
I had no audibles that's what we were we
were a basic offense at Texas I mean
like six play ran ten plays and we were
just better than everybody else except
for Oklahoma and we couldn't beat them
because their talent level is equal but
I was a novice when I got to the NFL
I mean Jon Gruden if we had him on here
one of his peers yeah which one of his
first conversations he made fun of me
he's like I don't get it he said why
can't your team pick up the splits
against Oklahoma it's the 15th time
they've run it and you guys and I just
said I don't know I was told not to
worry about it all week we were gonna
pick it up I did then and he just like
nobody taught you anything no I just
I made my proper ID we blocked that guy
but they told me they were gonna pick up
this blitz all week and we didn't pick
it up so again that's what I what he
says well he just saw hole you're gonna
learn some football here I mean you know
that [ __ ] ain't gonna happen but yeah
that's that's all I'm trying to say and
I'm not trying to crap a dinner lossky
knows a lot of football you know that
I'm just trying to say that would be an
instance to me to where you're judging a
little unfairly I think it's I think
we're at that time where the rumors are
starting up and the fake rumors are
starting up and you're we're like going
over tape for like the 80th time right
speaking of the Super Bowls Josh Rosen
an ESPN interview said I'd say six
titles is what I'd like to win but if
Tom Brady gets six I'll say seven yes go
for him I love it
yeah well I want Rosen and Odell on the
same team even though the rumors are the
Giants won't take them because maybe the
cockiest quarterback wide receiver duo
ever well let's see again this goes
again into like how we just stick with
themes of guys cuz deshaun Watson said
this last year too of course
but no so you're supposed to say I know
it's how I suppose you to win you know
what I'm okay if I don't win any he's
not a complete yes are people like seven
he's too cocky right I'd like for you
just want to be in second place yeah so
what is the response to him saying that
has everybody already like Aussies so
cocky he's already thinking oh I saw
it's like he's not short of confidence
yes like that yeah well he's a baller
so eat that yeah I agree all right let's
give Phil a call Phil is down in
Barbados Barbados has no idea we're
gonna call him right now
text message do you think he's in the
Sun no do you think he's like in the
light he's gonna be in the library fake
watching film he's probably not even
well what does fake watching film you
knows probably just he'd like to use
that light I'll be down here just
watching film guys no you have it
there's no internet at that hotel dad oh
okay yeah we'll say Oh yep see that's
that overseas ring right there that's
that roaming charge oh my god I hope he
answers yeah he's there mama looka boo
boo days there hey Phil what's going on
it's your favorite two idiots it's left
ko and soon and we just wanted to say I
hope Barbados is going great we just
want to leave a voicemail while we're
live on the podcast and unfortunately we
won't be able to get to you tomorrow
nope Phil in time is gone I hope you're
getting some Sun down there I mean you
are the whitest man on planet earth
right now and I hope you didn't spend
all that money to Barbados to just sit
in the hotel room so go get some Sun
don't fake film watch actually watch
that fat guy and we'll talk to you next
week
love you Phil good night dad see ya see
ya hang up awesome
okay that was tiring let's just make
sure that the number doesn't get out
there I hope we blacked it out all right
so last week we were talking about the
cornerbacks or two weeks ago all right
and what of our last week was it last
week and one of the guys that we didn't
get to was Kevin Tolliver Yeah right I
felt bad and I got the scouting report
here but I want to hear yours really
quick because I need to figure out who
sent me the the Kevin Tolliver okay so
why don't you start off this the LSU kid
you didn't get to it last week
actually first why don't you talk about
Denzel Ward we had a comment that's that
and then you can look it up we had a
comment that came and I think it was on
YouTube right and it said hey I noticed
that sim says the phrase this isn't my
type of corner right type of guy and it
would be really helpful if we knew what
Sims looked for in a position yeah and
you said Denzel Ward's not really my
type of guy yeah what kind of a guy is
it again this is not a negative okay I'm
not talking negative here Denzel word is
certainly
top 10 top 15 worthy and if he goes
there I'm not gonna sit there and
complain and go oh my gosh I can't
believe they drafted Denzel Ward how
stupid of them no that's not what I'm
gonna do but I think the thing that I
like when I just say Denzel Ward's not
my type of guy I just think this is this
is it in the nutshell I don't
necessarily love his body right he plays
small he looks small on the field to me
I don't love his ability to break on the
ball bursts accelerate all those phrases
that you use in the scouting world where
okay yes let's just say he's covering a
slot receiver and the slot receiver at
six yards runs a sharp out route I don't
like his ability then stick his foot in
the ground and try to break on the ball
and make that happen nor do I like his
contact or his ability to play physical
with 50/50 balls I found the two often
that players end up catching the ball on
him and I really think that at the end
of the day I just question it a little
bit that maybe his style won't translate
to the NFL as good as it looks in
college trust me there is this guy's the
man I'm not again this is not about like
trying to crap on this guy but I was
trying to say more than a cage I err
Alexander is more my type of guy why I
just like the look of the man better I
think he's a stronger guy especially at
the line of scrimmage getting jams on
receivers
I like his ability to accelerate and
burst more - he makes more plays on the
football and I think he has more
strength to knock the ball out or do
ever what it may but yes er Alexander's
ability to pay off and break on a ball
is Marcus Peters ish right he's got that
kind of stuff right or like he reminds
me of very much a William Jackson who
came out of he
for a few years ago and really was one
of the best corners in football last
year for Cincinnati I would say watch
out for him because gonna be in the
conversation this year but that's the
things I like I think it's just a hair
more twitchy and explosive than a Denzel
award with the strength and the punt
returning skills Denzel Ward is more
smooth and fluid and all that and that
in this again it's that's a great thing
to have he is that but I just don't know
when he has to play the ultra twitchy
receivers I don't see him always closed
the gap as well as junior Alexander will
earn does I just think there's a little
bit more of a twitch and explosiveness
explosive is there so that is Sims
clarifying Denzel Ward right this is
Conor O'Neill Connor was gracious that
we even said his name well guess what
now we're reading your scouting report
because we're gonna do Kevin Tolliver
the second Tolliver the second at first
glance is big six to 192 great for
playing press fast feet quick hips while
playing from press and he doesn't easily
give up his position that being said he
was sidelined the end of 2017 with a
knee injury something that might impact
his lateral quickness downfield he plays
aggressively with the ball in the air
but sometimes can be slow out of breaks
at the college level he is the speed to
make up for a slow break but to be
successful the NFL he's gonna need to
work on compacting his break well
finding his feet more in line with his
hips right which will enable him to come
out of his break more exclusive
explosively when tackling he needs to
work on his form
not a sound tackler but he's not one to
shy away right bottom lined he has the
nastiness to takes what is the nastiness
it takes to play quarter in the NFL he
has the size and skillset to be an NFL
corner but will need to work on his
tackling and speed out of breaks to be
successful yeah a lot of good things
they're said I see that what's our man
Kevin here Conor O'Neill Conor O'Neill
Connor I mean he he he's he sees the guy
a lot way this is guy was a pleasant
surprise to me when I turn on the film
really he really was
I think this kids a player first of all
I think Connor is very right we're like
his long speed his that it's
questionable it's not like top n it's
not Denzel Ward or how Alexander R
Hughes when you watch it on film but
this kids a big kid 6-3 204 has
tremendous hips and feet I mean he
really does he talks about the taco
tackling I understand that I don't
grade too harshly on tackling from
corners we haven't talked about Marcus
Peters tackling and since he's been in
the NFL we talked about his
interceptions and his coverage ability a
lot so listen at the NFL they'll get him
down I'm not looking for perfect form
tackle all the time but I wrote to the
this kid really reminds me of Josh
Norman that's who I wrote down is my his
movements it's very similar Josh Norman
a - Norman's issue he ran for six six
coming out I went and looked his 40 time
and I was like man he looks like Josh
the way he moves and of course I saw
Josh train in New Jersey and so I just
have a good feel for what his body is
overall but out of these big corners
left ko like you know I put these guys
in a different class like a Kevin
Tolliver I'm not gonna put him in the
same class okay as Denzel warden gyre
Alexander this is a different animal
okay this is a different guy this Kevin
Tolliver is in the class of more of the
Isiah Oliver from Colorado the Josh
Jackson from Iowa and then our man
Carlton Davis from Auburn and out of
those guys I mean Tolliver I really I
like him better than the kid Oliver from
Colorado for sure Kevin Tolliver over
Isiah all I do without a now I am NOT a
fan of the Oliver kid from Colorado at
all I just think it's too slow there's
no twitchiness or explosion there I see
the length and when he opens up he can
go but I don't got all day for Anna
waiting for to open up so I wrote so top
end there's only thing I don't like I
would say he's at four five eight type
of speed
let's see what's at the hell did I write
there first thing he does is Oh first
thing he does to help lack of top-end
speed is he's really good at staying on
top of wide receivers I mean he cuz his
length he's great at jamming at the line
of scrimmage he stays on top of them and
then he kind of smothers them to where
they can't run by him he's kind of
always running in their path so he does
a very good job and he realizes that
lets see good and zone solid tackler can
watch quarterback and the can watch
quarterback and receiver at the same
time and still make great great burst on
the ball which you know I like that
because it shows this ability to play
zone and sit there and read the play and
then go let's see how your short hands
are pretty good kid can do kid can do it
all on an island and for me I wrote he
was a 40
somewhere between 45 and 65 I mean just
has tremendous feet and hips very
impressed with it just has changed
direction ability his ability to burst
like I said out of the backpedal the
only thing I said was how fast is he
actually I said he plays fast but the
top-end speed is just not elite but out
of the big cornerbacks he is most
impressive one other than Carlton Davis
from Auburn especially in man demand
that's right and I'm glad I've read the
rest of this because compared to Josh
Jackson and Isiah all Isiah Oliver
Kevin Tolliver is a way better
man-to-man corner than they are and that
to me makes them a better corner because
you can teach you how to play zone I
mean that's not that hard oh oh you're
gonna midpoint this guy or we're gonna
teach you to read this whatever it may
be I want to be able to see the skills
to make special things happen and I
think that's where yeah I think he's in
that conversation with Josh Jackson who
I don't think her first-round corner
right gotcha I think I was up there with
the second round guys yes I think he's
in the second round because the lack of
true top-end gifted speed is going to
scare some people also Josh Jackson
Isiah Oliver fall another spot with
Kevin Tolliver coming up yeah I do I
like this Tolliver kid I really did I
didn't realize he even got hurt there at
the end of the year but either way I
don't think so I don't think people
realize why the draft on bleeped reports
gonna be so good this year usually I
would say three years ago Sims and
Miller probably did about 2,000 videos
before the draft so you guys already
knew your takes about Greg Robinson and
Jadeveon Clowney and all that stuff and
then the Jamis year was at the year
after that right yeah and then Jameson
Mariota we probably did about like a
thousand videos right forehead and we
kind of knew it again last year we
probably did about 200-300 this year
yeah you guys have done zero your videos
together right and what's great is when
we first start going you guys have your
have your opinions draft night me you
Miller for all of those hours live right
on Facebook bleacher report page report
Facebook and it's gonna be awesome yeah
because I think it's gonna be a
legitimate discussion of being like you
like him yeah I like him a lot you don't
like I think it could be really rare and
interesting yeah and I'm just excited
cuz I've never I don't remember ever
being live with something I don't know
the answers to
yeah right I'm excited I think it's I
know in other years I was willing to
draw a line in the sand and be like no
you're you're you're Miller you're dumb
for this one whatever it may be I mean
not knowing that I'm not saying that
like literally I'm just going like no I
totally disagree yeah I do think that
this year there will be good
conversation because like like we're
talking with the corners I just think
there's car gonna see a lot of people
who see it different ways even than the
NFL oh I like this guy just a little bit
kind of this or this guy funny thing
about the draft is we look at when guys
get drafted to validate who is right
about the quarter but yes though if this
Arnold goes one right you're wrong yeah
doesn't mean anything right and a lot of
time this draft is about value and where
they think the other teams are valuing
them as well so you pick a guy in going
man I have this guy here and this guy
there yeah but there's a be a long time
before I pick again or whatever it may
be and that falls into the the equation
as well I'm gonna wrap up with this wrap
up with this you know apparently your
top draft pick the animals was a lion
but man according to our good friends
say SAR say Sarpy on you should have
taken the Siberian tiger I mean I would
did I take a line in the first traffic
because Siberian tigers my favorite
animal my little girl told you that the
first time I can't my sister right
Siberian tiger is the largest living
ever to exist on earth and they prey on
musk deer deer
gorel wap ET the also knows for prey on
brown and black bear in siberia on the
other side grizzly bear feed on prey of
moose and deer this the Siberian tiger
grizzly bears also hunt and kill black
bear rarely who but I say what man I'm
just looking at it the sub a your entire
is a far better hunter both grizzly and
Siberian tiger Paul swipes are equally
powerful but Tiger is more technical
than a grizzly tech well
Siberian tiger canine teeth are longer
and thicker than grizzly bright right
crews a bear is slightly only slightly
heavier longer and taller than the
Siberian tiger yeah Siberian tiger
she used to kill brown bear for its food
and Russia when there was lack of
natural prey Wow so they only killed him
when they were bored right man out of
food right yeah don't mess with them see
a grizzly bear you're not too in Russia
Siberian tiger alone once killed a pack
of three wolves at a time which I think
grizzly can't do this is apparently
someone wrote this this is awesome I
like this well I mean this is my
favorite animal in the world right
absolutely we kept it with bears and
lions because there's actual bears and
lions football team right I mean come on
we all know that Siberian tigers in a
wipe the floor with some fat grizzly
bear so here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna reach out to the podcast listeners
picking two mascots from the NFL what
should be our battle next is it a Raider
versus a Viking is it a Falcon versus a
cardinal is it going to be a Titan
versus a jet I don't know you guys
decide and then we'll figure out which
LaVon us is taking which side and we're
gonna argue to the death and then we'll
bring in big Phil and he'll be the judge
okay fine all right
big Phil get a tan I mean he came back
with a tan what there's no way there's
no way he comes out like at like 5:30 he
will come out of his hotel room or
inside or wherever it is and I'm telling
you you're gonna go man does that guy
have white paint on his face and I'm
gonna go yes it is if it's called
sunscreen but it looks like white paint
any only wears it when the sun's beating
to set he only will go out when the good
Sun is beginning to set but he's still
gonna put sunscreen on like it's the
middle of the day and it's 90 oh he
comes out with like a look out like a
mrs. Doubtfire face of sunscreen yes
like not even just on the nose and some
long-sleeve shirt with probably a big
brimmed hat yes like it's so like a
safari hat it's so horrible I mean it
really is I mean it's unbelievable and
you thought your dad was embarrassing
all right forces no we're not done cuz I
got to do one more thing don't play the
music don't play the music sorry back
off music I got to talk about the
charity that I'm involved because I got
to give them some love it's a special
thing that I'm being a part of or have
been asked to be a part of and it's
called Friends of
right and I just want to tell everybody
what an awesome organization it is they
take kids with cancer and they pair them
up with teams organizations and
companies in their communities
for awesome experiences to brighten kids
lives up a little bit who have been
dealing with a lot of tough issues and
in life has not been easy
so we hosted a kid a few weeks ago you
met him Charlie awesome he was awesome
kid right came here he got him the mic
with us talk some ball we brought him
around the office his hump about Tom
Brady right I took it he took it I
kicked his button and horse I wasn't
gonna show many favoritism there he
doesn't deserve that he actually
appreciate it I know you didn't want any
any charity case there but right now all
right so this is what I want to talk
about friends of Jacqueline is raising
money for these kids and they're hosting
a raffle right is this raffle will be
figured out I believe at the dinner that
I am going to be hosting that you're
very excited to see me ho Sims is
emceeing an event right which means that
Sims is going to try and tell jokes and
I don't know how they're gonna go I just
know but you can buy one of these
tickets for $25 and if you and if you
win you get you get in entered into a
chance to win a two-day trip to Disney
okay for four people
that's all right so WWBT do slash help
cure so that's WWBT do slash help cure
and that will take you to the page where
you can donate and you can help out
Sophie and and your guy Charlie and all
the Friends of Jacqueline that donate to
that cause it's really it really is a
great cause it's it's a great little
organization and how they put this
together to brighten kids lives and I'm
really I'm glad to be a part of it I had
a guy just have really approached me
about the gym to get involved I thought
it was a it sounded like something neat
to be a part of I know you're really
excited I'm gonna buy you front-row
tickets so you can watch me but
regardless if you do have a chance you
get a extra spare $25 throw it out there
see if you can win a trip to Disney
awesome Sims is doing good things and
now I'm feeling self-conscious so I'm
gonna go hold the door for somebody and
give a dollar to homeless you're so
bad I know but you're great proud of you
all right guys as always support us some
social items in Lefko if you want to add
to that reddit page I check it every now
and then it's pretty funny for Simms
peace out homies federic says good
evening and the lef koe mam says good
night hope you guys enjoyed Joe Montana
wish me luck at jury duty and we will be
a hollering at you a little bit later
next week talk to you guys soon get on
the chair